ibrahim est avec nous merci brahim
d'être là parce que vous expliquez votre
position et votre voix là alors je vous
le dis est ce qu'on peut mettre les
lumières et cetera chez oui ils vous
disent y pense et favorise la production
favori certains candidats non la merci à
la production de se réveiller
ibrahim qu'est ce qui s'est passé ils
sont tous d'accord avec voulant plus
abattu peu de rythme voilà je suis
révoltée contre des agissements de
l'émission toc rester calme à cause est
révolté et donc les agissements dit nous
exactement leaf en fait au fur et à
mesure que je regarde l'émission je me
rends compte qu'en fait qu'il ya plein
de choses on met la lumière sur plein de
points mais pas sur d'autres
c'est à dire c est ce qu on va voir si
vous voulez avoir une image de vous ils
vous ont montré ces vrais sous un angle
ou les téléspectateurs vous cite macho
odieux et c'est vrai que pour vous
derrière c'est pas évident est ce que
vous vous avez le sentiment d'être macho
odieux comme on a pu le voir sur les
réseaux sociaux est ce que c'est le
montage qui a fait qu'on a eu cette
perception de vous je dessine je le suis
c'est que tous les grands chefs tous les
chefs au monde
ils sont ils sont machos c'est que si
c'était tout pour vous n'avez fait que
votre travail c'est le travail c'est le
coach le doubs le tarn coups de feu
c'est c'est la qualification
c'est c'est pendant le coup de feu c'est
voilà c'est toujours comme ça peut-être
que peut-être que quand on s'en prend la
tête qu'ils avaient prise de tête qu'on
lève le temps mais c'est courant dans la
cuisine on n'en coûte reçu courant alors
on va voir votre va voir un petit peu
comment vous étiez et quel était votre
comportement de top chef
regardez
ce concert des coques ou je te
regarderai ça arrivera je préfère des
sept plus imagé rien pour suis un peu
d'accord préparé puis après on verra ce
qu'on aura dans l'assiette
donc la solution moi je vais partir sur
mon premier service jeunesse partir je
pense qu'il est bien en tête donc je
fais le à noter qu est pas à me lever
son bien dans ma tête
ne t'inquiète pas je ne pars pas dans ma
tête jusqu'à bac moins un décès a montré
que c'est une très très bonne cuisinière
les craintes qu'elle me demande de faire
beaucoup de concessions et que voilà je
n'arrive pas à faire ce que j'ai envie
de faire
tu veux que je fasse quelque chose
différemment dans ma recette ou est-ce
que tu as ta réchauffement on va pas
rester par les 1/4 d'heure les hommes il
ya un peu de beurre maintenant essayer
des patrons il ya je suis sûr et certain
qu'il ait pas du tout crin je suis
cuisinier comment alors mais franchement
ibrahim moi cette séquence elle m'a
vraiment dérangé apparemment la
production était d'ailleurs plutôt sympa
avec vous parce que j'ai eu des infos
comme quoi alexia vais pleurer après
cette séquence parce que j'avais été
très dur avec elle alors peut-être que
pour vous c'est le fait des grands chefs
de parler comme ça à une femme moi ça me
choque profondément
et vous pouvez comprendre aussi que les
téléspectateurs soient choqués de vous
voir parler comme ça c'est le pauvre
alexia qui franchement essaye de vous
donner des conseils
et si vous avez été éliminés vous savez
très bien pourquoi première épreuve au
avez raté votre crème hier et votre
rideau il n'est pas cuit donc je suis
désolé c'est pas là
[Applaudissements]
faut dire la vérité sans rivaux ils
n'étaient pas cuites çà en tournée moins
bon alors est-ce que ce rythme n'était
pas cuit à ibrahim sur le point de ris
de veau
je me rappelle bien que jean françois
piège elle a dit qu'ils n'étaient pas
que ça que la cuisson la scène dérange
pas d'accord oui d'accord mais le défi
ici affaire grave
croyez moi il ya deux ans j'ai raclé
noblet tout vous dire ça merci la
riveraine on met donc au bout le rythme
où il était réussi votre ibidule pas
pour ceux qui nous rejoignent là on y
vit il était bâclé mais je comprends ce
que je dis pour moi le ris de veau pour
moi c'était la bonne cuisson
pour moi c'était bon c'est çà et là mais
bon ça fait débat la crème pourrait pour
le pour le point de la crème
justement c'est ça que moi ça m'a
révolté pourquoi ils n'ont pas montré
que c'était la recette de florian et
florian il m'a dit je suis sûr de mars
est ludique lorient est ce qu'il manque
deux pas de gélatine dedans à skis et
pau yves qu'il faut pas monter le très
puissant lardinois surtout c'est ma
recette je sais ce que je fais et alexia
et là à cep ont pâtisserie et me dit
ibra pour que tu veux tu pourquoi tu
veux toujours fait un truc fait comme il
a dit c'est comme ça moi je suis
cuisinier est là elle est là et le lac
ramatuelle à la crème la gauche qui
veulent monter en fait il ya deux façons
soit on a conclu le commença maillon
fort mais relativement dit non c'est
comme moi je suis à la lettre
je lui fais confiance nos résultats sont
là mais le problème
alors moi personnellement je suis je
trouve que ça va trop loin la vérité et
c'est pas la cuisine des mousquetaires
est ce qu'on prend dans le décompte
derrière moi ce qui m'a ce qui m'a ce
qui m'a énervé
pourquoi on montre pas la séquence où
florian il dit non garde la recette
telle qu'elle est mais moi j'applique
l'art tellement belle qu'elle pourquoi
il montre juste que moi j'ai raté là
j'ai raté la mousse lesotho s'ils ont
raté la mousse ou pas non c'est moi qui
l'ait fait moi je ne causera pas de tous
les missions et moi j'ai regardé le look
souffre en fait juste arrêtons pas parce
que la vie quand dans star ac et debbie
ses meilleurs chanteurs qui gagne depuis
quand dans koh lanta c'est celui qui
fait la cabane et le feu qui gagne
celui-ci impliquant des émissions de
cuisine c'est le meilleur que j'ai géré
ses émissions de télé ont fait un
casting
la prod a doit mener une mission à son
terme avec les meilleurs candidats
possibles et quand ils s'en foutent
royalement nationale qui fait bien de
sabayon et l'autre la béarnaise c'est
pas le propos ils veulent des personnes
aveugles et perso c'est tout
marouane marouane ils ont avancé ce que
disent les gens disent qu'ils avantage
marouane ce qu'il est très mise en avant
dans l'émission fin dans tout les aînés
peut-être pas parce que parce qu'il est
très cool parce qu'elle est très bon
c'est un showman psa et c'est un grand
ami à moi enfin je ne reviendrais de à
marouane je sais beaucoup jusqu'au bras
et vos goûts et vous vous juste à suivre
d'être facile juste un point sur ce
point d'histoire la main francs 15 je me
suis alors son monde à l'air mon dernier
et tv interview j'ai pété les plombs
devant le chalet à la journaliste elle
coupe le micro et me dit ibra les gens
et s'attache aux histoires c'est vrai
mais ils sont pas trop technique il des
la plupart ils auraient l'audience il
cherche pas la technicité et la marche
des histoires s'est arrêté et ça me
révolte encore plus ils ont été freinés
le moins désobligeants tesfran les deux
acteurs mais il est armé dont les
émissions c'est qu'ils ont été francs
grâce à la production mine de rien mais
c'est la journée ce qui m'a dit ça c'est
pas la production interne c'était
complet métro et m'a dit ibra je n'ai
juste un truc vous qu'est ce que vous
leur reprochez aujourd'hui la production
est haï 6 c'est juste qu'ils cherchent
plus des des shows du show que des bons
cuisiniers c'est ça oui c'est justement
ça bon alors je me dis après dix ans
après 10 ans d'expérience ils savent
comment chercher à l'audience d'accord
ce sont nous connaissons votre caractère
aussi donc avoir un look sur votre
caractère
et si on vous dit votre camarade est
très sympathique ils ont mis une loupe
sur le côté très sympa de votre capture
de membres des groupes là où vous êtes
l'épousé vos produits vos pris en haute
estime et non non non non
s'il vous plaît j'ai pas envie de la
voir dans merde je me positionnerai pas
dans la sphère du rideau est en revanche
c'est que la collection ça serait même
une fois le professeur will à favoriser
les candidats les plus charismatiques
vieillissant qui doit durer trois mois
ont gardé les mains d un genre c'est au
détriment de ce bastion des rouges
gd message est un message du président
de la chaîne qui me dit il et il est
énervé il se contrôler ibrahim est très
touchant voilà donc vous voilà le
président qui nous regardent et francs
capitaux et ses rites moi je vous trouve
très touchant je pense que vous avez été
déçu parce que je suis persuadé que vous
êtes un passionné de cuisine soit c'est
ce que je ressentais sur les verts ce
soir vous êtes sincère moi je trouve que
les candidats quels étaient ces
personnes comme ça qu'elle est on a ri
jaune a besoin on a besoin de gens comme
vous en télé ibrahim sory au lycée
rémois je vous le dis franchement
et si je comprends que vous soyez déçu
mais je vous jure que c'est vrai le
problème c'est que la télé et ça c'est
un show partout et mine de rien c'est
comme dans ce vol on dit aussi au départ
c'est la réa et peu après il ya le
physique qui joue beaucoup
moi j'ai pas jeter chez topshop ai
envoyé mon cv
ils ont appelé le restaurant ils ont dit
est-ce que vous avez un bon candidat oui
moi quand j'ai contacté ils ont dit oui
où as tu veux tu t'intéresses moment je
suis parti en tant que cuisinier je suis
pas parti pour faire le show moi je
reste moi mais non ça c'est sûr
maintenant si les gens il est ma
personnalité au pas ça c'est ça c'est ça
leur arrive je pense que l'émission
pourrait s'appeler de soirée top chaud
voilà parce que je suis fière jury c'est
vrai mais c'est ce qu'ils cherchent
autant du show mais déjà sur l attention
j'avais beaucoup de talent il est dirigé
par un passionné et je suis persuadé que
vous allez faire une grande carrière
dans la cuisine
dans les émissions comme ça et forcément
je vous dis la vérité
ils cherchent par un cercle à faire de
l'audience les ide on va garder parmi
les candidats qui sont le plus le show
et écluses et devient donc votre cuisine
chaussures ce n'est pas du tout remise
en cause et je suis persuadé que vous
allez gilles artaud n'est qu'un chauffe
un gros bisou voilà merci